- You know, shoutout to Trae Young, man.
I know he gon' watch this.
- What you think about his haircut?
- I feel—I've never seen him with a fresh haircut.
[Ding]
No, no offense, Trae Young.
- What's good? It's your boy, VicBlends.
I'm out here with Bleacher Report
for the NBA Tip-Off 2021
and we're trying to find some
NBA fans to give a free haircut to,
- Free haircuts for NBA fans.
OK, cool.
I'm an NBA fan.
- As long as you an NBA fan.
- Oh yeah, dawg.
- All right, let's do it.
- Yeah man, I usually don't let anybody
just cut my hair, you know?
I got barber PTSD.
- Who do you got winning it all
this year?
- Brooklyn.
- Brooklyn?
- I mean, I think
LeBron and the Lakers
will be at the end again.
- For sure.
- Even though I hate 'em.
- They got an All-Star team right now,
right?
- Yeah. I mean, if they don't win,
then that's just embarrassing.
- What's your predictions
for the Hawks?
- I think they gon' do good,
only because I have to.
Like me, I'm real loyal
when it comes to stuff like that,
so, even if we don't do good, you know,
I'm still gonna ride by 'em.
- That's right.
- What's that TikTok? I'mma stick beside 'em?
- Hey, you got to.
What do you think about
Trae Young's haircut?
- Ooh.
- I feel—I've never seen him
with a fresh haircut.
No, no offense, Trae Young.
- He might need to cut it all off,
no lie.
- He need a better barber, right?
- Yeah.
- I wonder who be cuttin' him.
- I don't know, but they are
not doing him justice.
- I guess not.
You think he need a better barber?
- Yeah.
- But you cut Trae, right?
- [Laughing]
Yeah, I am
Trae's barber.
[Both laughing]
- I'm just messing with you.
- Do you cut him?
- I do cut him.
- OK, OK. How often?
- Pretty often. He gets it cut
pretty often, bro, but he's a hard—
- Man. It's TV, it's TV. I'mma say that's it's TV.
- He a hardworking man, though, man,
and you know, when you sweat,
it don't look the same.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I'm just gon' say, you know,
I probably got a small TV, it don't
have many pixels or something,
you know?
- Well, I mean, you're on thin ice.
I got a clippers to your head.
What was your first
basketball memory?
- Playing with my dad outside,
like on one of the hoops we had
in the cul-de-sac.
- Hey, my dad, like just beating me.
Like, I used to try to
play him all the time.
He would just beat me over and over
and over again, and it kind of made me
want to get better just so I can
beat him.
- Pops was your biggest enemy, yeah.
- Yeah.
That was literally my only goal.
- Through sports, you learn a lot about values, man.
It's about teamwork,
accountability. It's dedication,
working hard and
just lifelong friendships.
- How was basketball help
change your life?
- Basketball helped change me,
because it was a lot of times where
I have two different friend groups.
I have, you know, the friend group
that does the good things and
I have a friend group that does bad things,
and it just so happens I hoop so much
that I never have time to be with
all my friends that
get in trouble,
so it saved me a lot.
- So it was an escape for you?
- Yeah.
- Feel like it's an escape for a lot
of kids nowadays.
Put you back in the game.
Mustache goin' crazy.
Faded the back out too.
- That's great, man. I appreciate it.
- Man, where the females at?
- [Laughing]
- Where the females at, man?
What are we doing, man?